he said he said the name he sees a
sickness
he said the name of your name the moment
I looked at this one's forehead I could
see the Horn of Africa like he had a
horn himself huh
hello how's it going you know I was
doing pretty good when now I'm
blindfolded
does it make you nervous to be
blindfolded yeah the last time that I
experienced something like this was
training for scuba diving is that like
something you do for like work or just
fun I like how you slip that [ __ ] in
there last time I got blindfolded was
when I was in the gym working on my
six-pack the last time I had to put on a
blindfold is when I realized my bank
account I hit one million dollars and I
was just raking in that money [ __ ] but
he 100 threw that [ __ ] in there
regardless I'm a scuba diver the last
time I put on a rifles when I woke up
and I realized I had a 12 inch dick what
were you saying babe just fun so you
can't see each other no say something
sexy
you know I thought he was gonna say so
you can't see each other so touch your
titty and I was like work let's go
you can also have 12 hands I'm
comfortable with whatever sure and I
have a lot of house plants and I go out
with friends
it's hard to get I was worried that he
was gonna hit it so I wanted to hit it
first well I haven't even I haven't even
been able to learn much the preemptive
rejecting is probably the most
interesting part about the button for me
because it shows how much
people act out of fear he didn't hit the
button because one he doesn't know what
she looks like and he's like listen I
just want to get to know her like it's
cool you know if it doesn't go well it's
fine she's operating from this thing of
like I want to meet somebody but I'm
also I hate through the feeling
rejection so they're operating from two
different places yeah yeah and is that
would you say that that's on the button
or in real life I think it's both yeah
yeah how about this how about I tell you
men reject themselves every day oh okay
go to the club they start talking to
them if they don't think it's going with
a leaf even though they could have
turned it around but in their head
they're so programmed to see themselves
negatively they walk out or if a girl
comes up and confesses the guy in his
head has already thought he's a he's
garbage so he doesn't believe in the so
you see it in the position and man but
you see it in woman yeah I think even
women do because here's an example and
women will relate to this women will not
swipe right on certain hot guys because
they don't feel like he's out of the
leak or he's gonna leave them or he's
not going to be really interested in
other than just to [ __ ] them and then
track them away how many times you've
seen black women be like he must be into
white women I've never seen that
you get what I'm saying what is that
them doing yeah it's rejecting yourself
um do you like naughty girls who doesn't
I suppose the next question should be
are you a naughty girl absolutely I used
the mistletoe native deodorant today
damn that oh my God that ant insert was
awkward I'm a I'm a yo listen I'm an ad
in sir genius
that's what you use
this
are you a naughty girl
are you a naughty boy [ __ ] yeah I've
been using surf shark VPN to hide my IP
while I'm browsing these porn sites I
don't want none of these to know my
history and you can get surf shark too
for 30.
no keep on going that's a good end go go
get back masking your IP address is
incredibly important all right guys ad
reads over this video is brought to you
by surf shark hey sometimes you want to
watch certain videos from other
countries and you can because your
country is not allowed
I know well you need to get yourself a
VPN changer a VPN changer is something
that's gonna change the location of your
computer I'm from Canada and our Netflix
is nice but it's not like the US Netflix
or the UK Netflix or any native no or
any Netflix around the world and
sometimes I want to be able to enjoy
that content well I just teleport my
computer with the VPN changer wherever I
want it to be and I can enjoy whatever
content I want and now now if you if you
you go on the link below you use the
code Abba and preach you're going to be
able to save 85 and have three first
month for free I know I I know go right
now click on the link below and you know
let your computer travel
and you will enjoy all the content that
you want
you're welcome sir I'm telling you
nobody in the history of YouTube as use
the NAD to promote another one
oh you want to do an adary [ __ ] okay we
gonna play today let's play place
[ __ ] oh I got a second sponsor of this
[ __ ] how do y'all feel about clear skin
huh cause fresh okay
all right
right now fresh my man's 28 going on 80
and I don't want that to be you guys and
that's why today's sponsored the last
challenge can you take your blindfolds
most nerve-wracking part
Gonna Hate what you see oh my God you're
gorgeous is this the type of person you
normally would date honestly no
but all these [ __ ] out there
want on this team you got it now oh my
God you're so [ __ ] hot would you date
her no
why
[Music]
am I going to be canceled I think this
is how hard you have to breathe normally
foreign
I don't know like even even with looks
um I don't have a type
what did I do honestly I feel like it's
because I'm heavy
no no that's the vibe I got
you didn't get that Vibe the same reason
you said it's because you're heavy is
the same reason you preemptively
rejected him or try to earlier it's
because you're insecure about your
weight because you've realized that in
your dating life it's been an issue it's
not a Vibe it's you projecting your own
insecurity on it
and maybe you're right maybe maybe
you're right but you amplify that [ __ ]
yeah I would I wouldn't say
automatically that it's a Vibe you are a
good kisser though thank you sorry you
thought she was saying he was not
attracted to you yeah it's it's been
pretty common in my experience you
talked with someone for a while and then
when they see me in person they're like
oh actually I don't know if I'm feeling
it that was the vibe I got I have to ask
what do your pictures look like where
people see you in person then they get a
different vibe
that's kind of weird to me not gonna lie
not gonna lie
I have to ask you this to anybody if you
go on dates and people right off the top
are not feeling the way that you look
what are you promoting in your pictures
now maybe you're just a bad dater or
like on a date people start to hate you
but I have the opposite experience I
didn't get nearly as many dates as other
guys I knew when it came to online
dating but every day I went on went
really really well in the sense that she
wanted a second date because I
underrepresented my looks I mean people
say to me all the time Abba you look way
better in person I'm like hell yeah it's
good I hope you think I'm ugly oh my
good low expectations where the [ __ ] is
at because I'm not even gonna lie to you
I don't mind a [ __ ] with small titties
I don't like a [ __ ] you lying about her
small titties
you get what I'm saying if I came in
thinking you got double D's and you got
Ace
I don't like straight A students so it's
about to say though
[ __ ] I didn't know you was a [ __ ]
nerd that wasn't cool right I didn't
know you was a nerd [ __ ] I could have
sworn you like video games and [ __ ] huh
but
if I went into it like yo this nerd she
work at a library you know how I feel
about Librarians but get that book on
the top shelf let me look up under your
skirt I can get into that I could build
up that finish in my head
but if I came in for some double D
knockers like I was trying to re-up on
some milk and you showed up with the
books we got a problem because
expectations was different you hear me
ladies you can handle a small dick
but he was talking like he was packing
like Mandingo and Timberlands and
[ __ ] showed up in a polo and
Tennis Shoes you might be like this
wasn't the penis I was advertised
expectations
guys if you're listening that doesn't
mean you should take shitty [ __ ]
photos it just means that your photos
should be somewhat realistic if you're
five eight don't be taking no [ __ ]
angles and standing on those goddamn
boxes like you six three yeah that's all
I'm saying that's it post a picture of
you next to a camera yay
that's all I'm trying to say because
nobody like to be deceived by these
photos online hi hey how you doing good
my name is not home what's your name I'm
Megan what's your sign I'm an Aries
hey hey that that and I hope he's not
serious he's just trying to troll
actually you know you do look like a
[ __ ] boy he's probably serious I'm so
sorry I can't this Aries I had bad
experience
I told you I can smell that [ __ ] boy
energy out of him yeah you're talking
about goddamn signs
and and he look East African too
poof
lies okay my name is
may we go out sometime you feel me cause
sometimes we about to get an arm how
about sucking them toes you know
sometimes it's already on the button
she's trying to feel what a button was
yeah she got to be ready yeah what's
your name what's your home not home
where are you from to cry it's in
Northern part of Ethiopia
he said he said the name he sees a
sickness
she said the name of your name the
moment I looked at this one's forehead I
could see the Horn of Africa like he had
a horn himself huh this one has come on
the button and you have seen that the
forehead looks like a giant button
itself
there is a connection we are we are
tethered together in like this oh Coco
I'm Nigerian Niger okay
so you both are blindfolded she pulled
her hand away the moment she found out
he was black yeah shout out to you
Nigerian woman she said hey you a
brother
uh what's that where you from Russia
word
oh Ethiopia hey
she said she want that horn but she's
like ain't no way no white Devil's gonna
bust me out
what is your favorite color it's royal
purple and all gold oh there's gonna be
a writing colors that should be cool are
we talking about marriage yes are you
ready listen you paired the two Africans
in the room together is this red yet
[Applause]
why well I know why because I brought up
marriage you can't take a joke to be
honest I didn't understand her humor so
I didn't know if it was a joke or not
you don't like funny women turns out
you're jollof a little too sticky [ __ ]
you gotta go
it was from Ghana and we don't like
their [ __ ] jollof get them out of
here all the Guardians are gonna come in
the comments that's fine but all the
Nigerians are like yo we love this [ __ ]
and we got more Nigerian fans than guy
names it's a money move you gotta
understand I'm strategic about this [ __ ]
I can see that yeah when I got this
religious Palestinians you know how I
choose what I slide with where we got
more fans and we're not going to [ __ ]
Palestine to do a show so you already
know my [ __ ] what up Israelis they go
be bad
I mean I was gonna do a show in in
Russia a little while ago because I
thought they were going to win now they
lose I'm like yo what's up ukrainians
I'm so proud of you
I'm trying to shake your hand i'm High
pleasure pleasure
uh she beat you to it that's cool the
way their hands touched yeah so it's
like buying
do that [ __ ] again
um
excuse me I'm Amy I'm John so I roller
skate
um and I also dabbling into shooting
film oh you're in film I have a few film
cameras and I like to like go to places
around the city I love to like explore
abandoned buildings that's crazy because
I'm in film too oh [ __ ] what do you do
I'm an actor you're an actor okay I do
TV and film yeah that's great yeah yeah
I'm sorry oh my God I love this
see the reason why I would have Buzz is
whenever I meet somebody to tell me
they're an actor I'm like great you got
mental health issues fantastic oh you're
a narcissists goodbye [ __ ] oh you did
theater you're self-absorbed oh what was
that you did huh you did what you did a
play play yourself out these kids really
because this button going off right now
hey this is your Premiere get the [ __ ]
up out of here
[Music]
what the red carpet [ __ ] we roll that
out to that exit turn that left you know
I mean like outer
yeah out I remember one time I didn't go
to the theater and it was one of the
worst experiences of my life I never
seen corny being personified by a woman
ever like that one time we were in bed
this [ __ ] touched my nose like this and
she went your nose is so boopity you
told me that [ __ ] and I went flicked her
B and I said your [ __ ] so poopy you
feeling like you need that mean
girlfriend you ever notice every actor
got they [ __ ] pronouns in their bio
every actor seems to have the same
[ __ ] values and morals in terms of
what they expose politically yeah it's
like they're all assuming a role all the
time with acting there's so much
networking involved the ACT never stops
you get what I'm trying to say that's
what you're saying you know I mean if I
meet a dancer in the street we just talk
generally speaking even if it's about
dance we're just talking when I'm doing
the acting like sometimes they still do
in the ACT yeah you know what I'm saying
yeah that's cringy though yeah that's
what you're saying so that's the part
because they're always doing PR they're
doing these functions they're going to
these events they're doing all that [ __ ]
like that's corn and they all have to do
it because that's like the way to make
that [ __ ] is training too yeah we're
always doing that [ __ ] I don't know
actors no oh I just feel like the actor
I've dated people who've modeled in the
past and they were pretty like
self-involved
foreign
actor on meet them I
how do you unmute someone
block delete
thank you for the answer I didn't know
but let's find a solution because you
want to unmute them hi I'm Amy hi I'm
Matt about a bag
God I'm such a
I'm Annika hi I'm Amy hi Amy Annika how
old are you I'm 23. okay
sorry I really like this girl I'm not
gonna lie to you she's not [ __ ]
around yo yeah yeah hey what's up Serena
how old are you 18 word word that's dope
youth is a beautiful [ __ ]
go watch some sneako get the [ __ ] up out
of here you're gonna be like I got time
for this no no that's okay my name is
David hey David I'm from Georgia
living here is
different but it's cool I'm liking it
it's fun Vibes how's your day been um
are you like begging to astrology at all
or yes oh for sure my ex was really into
it okay really uh tore us apart
was that a joke yeah yeah Taurus is a is
a sign
um
why the hell are you rejecting me Amy
that was the worst joke I have ever
heard